there are complex political issues that
are oversimplified to hide bad policy
and then there are simple economic
issues that are made more complicated in
order to hide bad policy tax cuts are
one that we have a really good grasp of
right assuming that you're in a mixed
capitalist economy when there's a pseudo
free-market basically if things are like
things are in the United States when you
give poor and middle-income people a tax
cut or a tax credit they mostly spend
the money because they need the money
they're sort of short on money so they
need the money and they're going to
spend that money if you go to rich
people and you give them a tax cut they
disproportionately save the money
because their needs are met right if
you're used to going to expensive
restaurants you're not likely to go to
many more of them because you get a tax
cut for example and if you give big
corporations a tax cut they will not use
the money to hire people all else being
equal companies hire workers when
there's demand for their product or
service after the Trump corporate tax
cuts we heard anecdotes about this
company is giving raises that one is
hiring more people but they were just
anecdotes and that's why we call it
merely anecdotal evidence or data we
heard a couple dozen stories about that
we now have broader data from the last
year from S&P 500 companies and the S&P
500 is it's an index it includes 500
large publicly traded companies it's a
broader index than the Dow it's a more
diversified index than the Nasdaq which
is very tech heavy and those 500
companies that are part of the S&P 500
overwhelmingly spent their tax cuts on
buying back stock which increases the
value of that stock and helps the
executives and the rich people and they
spent that money on dividends which also
disproportionately helps their
executives and rich people and if you
know anything about basic finance and
economics you say of course they did
that of course they did that this is
such a simple thing if you think about a
tax rate as a cost ask yourself the
question would you rather avoid a high
cost or a local
a tax rate is the sort of opposite of an
interest rate that you make on money
that you have in the bank right if you
can choose between earning let's go with
Pat let's see if even Pat gets this and
I know now I don't mean that to be
dismissive I mean just let's see if Pat
understands what we're talking about
here if you can choose Pat between
earning two percent interest or four
percent interest on your money which
would you choose
I'll go with the four percent interest
why twice as much you make more money
Yeah right if you can choose Pat between
avoiding a two percent tax or avoiding a
four percent tax which would you choose
I'd like to avoid the four percent tax
and why is that it'll save me money
that's exactly right
when the tax rate goes down you are less
incentivized to avoid the tax by
investing in your company because those
investments are tax deductible when the
tax rate goes up you're more
incentivized to do things with the money
that will help you avoid the tax and
this came up during my interview with
Dave Rubin if you remember Pat like a
year or a year and a half ago it was a
moment of significant confusion that a
lot of people pointed out the only thing
here that's surprising is that the Trump
administration tried to say companies
would use the money for hiring when it
was obviously untrue and people bought
it because a basic understanding of
economics tells you if you lower the tax
rate on corporations it encourages
profit taking and it encourages just
buying up stock to drive the price up it
was obvious all along and shortly after
the Trump tax cuts were implemented they
did a story about how Morgan Stanley how
they put that extra money and I guess
the plurality of what they put that
extra money into or things like stock
buybacks and dividends yeah whereas only
like ten fifteen percent went to you
know raises and bonuses and the things
that we were promised and would like to
see happen well that ratio of like
roughly ninety ten or 85 fifteen that's
the ratio that the data more broadly is
pointing to which is that somewhere
between eighty and ninety percent of the
tax cuts to these big corporations have
been used to pay bigger dividends to
shareholders and executives and also to
buy back stock and last year we had
another report from the Institute for
Policy Studies which showed that when
you do a corporate
cut it boosts CEO and executive pay but
you don't typically see an increase in
jobs nor in the wages for the average
worker it's a really simple economic
concept that people who want corporate
tax cuts and tax cuts for the rich will
pretend is really complex in order to
get people on board with it
it's just bad policy plain and simple
and there is nothing surprising about
this except for the fact that people
keep falling for these obvious lies
discuss this with us on our subreddit
david pakman.com slash re d di t today's
program is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman if you've not already
heard about plinkus it's amazing it's an
app for your phone tablet or web browser
and what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a fifteen minute audio book
you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n